[Music]
the hodge twins back they went and took
a break during the they went took a
break and i was notified you you again
went into the bathroom together it's
warm in there man yeah it's real warm
well yeah when there's two of you yeah
this place is like a damn ice box why do
you both go into the bathroom what do
you do it's warm we're talking talk
about investments we talk about hey
there's a lot of white people in here
don't let your guard down you need a
safe space man in the bathroom
how many white people are in the
bathroom
we've been going to the bathroom since
we were kids you know we just take baths
together
yeah but usually that stops
yeah we don't do that anymore shut up
uh we're gonna go and take some of your
chats but one thing too we have an
upcoming week yesterday we went to the
gym together
and speaking of of differences uh and by
the way we have shows next week i think
brian callum's going to be in
a black woman when we were going to the
gym we were just walking and she leaned
out of her car
and she was saying something i turned
back and you guys were saying thank you
and i realized she was saying you two
were really handsome yeah right isn't
that yeah you said that happens all the
time yeah from black women yeah yeah
yeah women too
who white women yeah do you like that
dog oh yeah but
more chocolate but it's like a cultural
thing with black women they will tell
you
if you're if they find you good luck i
have gone my entire 33 years and never
once seen a white woman just say like
hey excuse me you're handsome
it's never happened never never i'm not
as handsome as you granted
usually it's usually it's a white woman
sending me are those mirrors on your
shoes and i say no
um
i don't know how this ties into that but
i'm just saying that's a perfect example
of a cultural of racial differences yeah
not none is better or worse than the
other but uh it's just different i've
never like usually have to be on the
third date for a woman to admit that
you're not repulsive with white people
it is a little bit different white
people don't really do that very much
white people don't it was surprising
they just said she's a girl just said
you're very she's an older woman too and
i will say black women i've talked about
this on air they always i've never once
had a black woman get uncomfortable or
not appreciate a compliment no right
white woman you got to be careful that's
like like wow you have a beautiful skin
are you going to rape me now no
[Laughter]
or the black woman was like wow i really
like you know usually i have like you
know super long nails i'm like oh that
was very interesting oh my thank you
oh that's so nice i will return your
merchandise here at kohl's and i will
allow you to keep the merchandise while
giving you a refund
and the one i've talked about is the one
black girl like who i dated two black
girls the one black girl who i dated as
an adult not in high school she was very
aggressive she makeout raped me oh yeah
yeah she makeout remy because i was i
was living in her mom's house at the
time her mom was a realtor and so i was
living in her mom's house in simi valley
because she was she lived in malibu she
said look you can just live in my house
you can show the house for me and keep
it clean so i don't have to drive all
the way out there yeah i was like wow
thank you because basically i was
homeless and uh
i was like
sleeping
but then her daughter liked me yeah and
i she was very she was pretty but i
didn't think it was going to work out
long term but the problem is i am in her
mother's house so i guess we're dating
now oh man this is getting hot don't
stop
sounds like a roommate
and this is this is a true story because
you know i've talked about this um
people were like well did you have no i
was i didn't have any sex at all my wife
had any sex before marriage not like
bill clinton like nothing and same thing
with this so she like lunged at me in
her mom's house and
you know
and then uh she was like so what do you
want to do when i felt like she was
trying to push for something i said i
don't know you want to go see a movie
and she said no and there was a gold's
gym in simi valley had like a cardio
theater i was like they have a cardio
theater we don't even need to pay we can
go see what they're showing look they're
showing jaws too he's like i don't want
to go to the gym i was like oh well i
guess i'll walk you to your car
so
she wanted you to go deep inside she won
she was very aggressive she was married
with child six months later when we
didn't continue clear plans with her
clear plans i thought she wanted someone
that i was not ready for at that point
and there's nothing she was a very nice
girl by the way uh but here's the truth
i walk her to her car okay good thank
you good night yeah i'm still a man i'm
trying to i'm trying to be a good
christian man and i just okay there's a
makeup thing and then um i walk into her
car and i say okay good night and i go
back and she's gone so i'm gonna lounge
and i'm then i switch into uh pajamas
which are nothing but basketball shorts
paper thin basketball shorts keep in
mind i'm still hot and bothered of
course
[ __ ] she's still there and she's like oh
you know what i didn't really feel like
going home and i like you can't hide it
with basketball shorts that's
unfortunate so now i'm walking around
with a loaded weapon yeah and i just i
didn't let her in the door like held it
like i was like there with a robe like
[ __ ] come on no i know
i know i know but the basketball show
was like this is so hard you know the
other side of the door like i said
horror movie i know most people would
not believe me with this but it was true
and that you know so in other words my
experience black women are very uh
aggressive yeah they are yeah which is a
good thing cause i'm shy
you're shy
really i would not expect you to sure
yeah growing up with us really i'm still
really sure a little like when i get to
know you i'm not shy anymore but
yeah i mean you you called me all sorts
of racial epithets
so what do you do the woman have to make
the first move on you yeah yeah because
i can't i cannot
i don't want to ask a woman for a number
and then get turned down i can't take
the rejection really i can't you
everybody dude
you don't get rejected a whole lot
you're good-looking guys
no i don't know so there you go they're
nice guys they're shy guys and you can
support them good guys uh at uh is it
official hodgetwins.com yeah that's our
website you can buy a nice patriotic
t-shirt today uh all right let's go to
some chat we have some chat for me and
for the twins
okay sydney writes morning crowded crew
thanks for all you do question what do
you think will be the next thing changed
from cancel culture don't know what this
first one is aunt jemima what next
what's barrel oh cracker barrel uh maybe
maybe she misspelled barrel oh she sense
a cracker
maybe it's because the chat auto sensor
the check is on this oh the chat auto
that's ridiculous um cracker bail on
jemima uncle ben's what have we changed
we've changed
we've changed uh uh uh redskins
indians didn't they just changed chiefs
too
i think they just changed chiefs which
was named after uh actually i think a
general or something the chief like it
wasn't actually it doesn't matter i'm
not mistaken i think they want to change
chiefs yeah it's tough to know i mean i
know what's left i mean redskins i'm
like okay all right
yeah i get it i still think you know you
shouldn't necessarily change it but uh
uh what is it also maybe probably the
chicago blackhawks do they change that
jersey yet we're still it's a beautiful
jersey with the feathers and stuff i
don't know i don't follow hockey it's
tough to know because you never would
have thought that they were canceling
people like jk rowling all right let's
go to another chat okay ashley webb
wants to know my school is hosting a
meeting titled exploring definitive
moments of whiteness what should i do
don't go
[Laughter]
okay this is so stupid how can you def
what the what is that what does it mean
how does and how does that help black i
don't understand how does that help the
idea this is done under the guys it
helps black people supposedly i would
imagine that it would create more racism
yeah it does i would think so yeah i'm
really concerned about it honestly
because i grew up so i grew up in in
montreal and our school did not have a
lot of black kids
but we had a lot of asians we had a lot
of middle eastern kids we had a lot of
specifically lebanese kids a lot of
muslims like we had prayer rooms um and
it was mostly a post-racial world in
both in the united states and in canada
like we had black but we didn't really
think about it so much you'd rib each
other
um
and i'm worried that there is no
post-racial america now there was
post-racial america for a period where
when i was growing up now does it mean
that i didn't does it mean that maybe i
didn't understand some of the race
individual races that black people face
of course i understand that there's
individual discrimination that everyone
faces that maybe i didn't face i have
different experiences because i was an
english-speaking canadian in french
canada where they had the language
police and if i opened stephen's
apostrophe s diner i was fined out of
business so there was actual systemic
discrimination against english-speaking
citizens in quebec so not by skin color
but by language but by where you were
born i did experience some of that
discrimination growing up and so i know
that it feels pretty crappy that being
said it's not the same here in the
united states there's no systemic
discrimination when we grew up there was
i would say post racial america because
who what were the shows that i watched
fresh prince of bel-air yeah family
matters it wasn't like we ever said we
watched the black show and the white
show even the shows that we watched like
power rangers were mixed right it was
just something it was just kind of like
it was never a thing tons of black stars
denzel washington will smith right
there's a ton of them but think about it
now what do you have now you have i
don't know i don't even know what's on k
but you would have like modern family
and then you have tyler perry and tbs
it's like now you have black people go
and it's like this is black people kind
of yeah
content exactly right we didn't really i
don't know i felt like we didn't have
that nearly as much when we were growing
up was way more mixed and now i think
the kids constantly being reminded
here's what worries me okay you
obviously haven't experienced this
because you're black no one ever came up
to you and said like we're going to
teach you class we have to recognize how
awful you are for being black so imagine
you're a white you probably need to
but imagine a white kid going to school
who's never owned a slave who's never
had a racist thought and he's going to
school and he has teachers telling him
no no you need to recognize your
privilege no privilege no no no no you
have problems no no you need to
recognize the horrible things that your
forefathers have committed you're bad
because you're what's going to happen
that kid's going to resent it and he's
going to say why are they doing this i
haven't done anything wrong oh because
black people want me to do this i may
have a problem but it's not black people
yeah it's it's it's feminist white
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah and i'm worried
that you're gonna have way more racism
in this generation because when you
vilify someone based on race they're
going to see race a lot more yeah this
there's way more racism in this country
now it all started in obama's
administration ever since then it's
getting worse and worse but that's what
they want and that's what we i remember
that was the one silver lining i thought
with barack obama being president i was
like okay socialist smoking crack with
bilayers all right supports babies you
know babies born alive letting them die
in a way like a pretty bad but the one
silver lining is at least there can be
total healing like now a black person
has it you know smith talked about it
for years being the first black
president
and now i said that'll at least be one
good thing and then it was just like the
racial union just cracked right been all
downhill from there it really who would
have thought that black who would focus
on that you would go from riots racial
riots like my dad in detroit in the 60s
and civil rights but which obviously
there was racism and obviously those
people experienced it and obviously we
need to understand history but who would
have thought that we went racial riots
uh skip a generation you have los
angeles individually but skipped it and
then
all black lives matter riots under the
first black president yeah if you would
have told us that in 1998 then it
escalated no one would have believed you
they're like what you're gonna have the
first black president and you're gonna
have the most violent racially motivated
riots ever how does that work
that's what we ended up with mainstream
media but they want to they want us to
think that it's because you know you say
some naughty words or you tell some
racially you tell some racially
motivated jokes that's what's really
causing the vision no it's not not
teaching young kids that they suck
because they're white
and not teaching young kids that they
need to let their stores be looted if
someone has the right skin color and not
tell it's not from telling young black
kids that they can't make it in america
just ignore
the the last president who served eight
years and his [ __ ] sidekick who's
now serving another four it's not
because of all this brow beating and
racial division and solely identifying
people by their race it's because uh
it's because kramer got up at an open
mic at la factory
yeah he got pissed
it was a bad moment don't get me wrong
but like that didn't breed new racists
yeah yeah people didn't watch that and
go oh you know he makes a compelling
argument
people go that guy's crazy what happened
with that that was heckling him right
yeah yeah they were heckling him and
then they turned the cam that was the
first sort of cancel thing and that
being said it was like everyone sort of
agreed this was horrible he shouldn't
have said this repeatedly said like he
didn't just say
n word he stuck stuck it with the er oh
yeah
he was saying the most the the hardest
thing for them he's going what can i
infin this person with right and then he
said that so i think it was horrible i
also don't think he's a racist
so my mom did just for last comedy
festival uh in montreal she was a
wardrobe sales and he was a host one
year
and he was debilitatingly shy because he
had never done really like live shows
like that he was more of a classic uh
classical actor right right right and i
think maybe at an improv background i
don't know but compared to like jerry
seinfeld or compared to john candy or
dame edna or joan rivers all these
people would come in and she'd have to
do the costumes and work with them she
said he was really nice but he was
really shy like i think he would like
throw up before he would get back in the
green room and he was really really
demure and shy and then he was just
trying to do stand-up and you know it's
a pressure cooker if someone heckles you
right at stand-up especially when you're
coming up now most people are there for
you yeah what happens is they say
something or they're trying to take over
the show the way you shut them down is
by stinging them so hard and so fast
that they don't want to speak again yeah
right and so you combine that with i
need to shut this guy up with a complete
lack of experience and that's where you
end up with michael richards saying all
that crazy racist stuff yeah all right
let's uh we have two more chats or one
yeah two more okay
all right so andrew griffiths wants to
know why does the show say louder with
crowder again instead of good morning
mug club joe biden has been getting all
the softball questions lately so i
figured it's about time you got one
thank you for the show you have a
positive impact on my life thanks for
that keep up the great work guys that's
a tough question i i appreciate the
question you know what it was as we so
when we did the mud club quarantine
month we sort of we had been doing you
know the night show which was louder
with crowder and we needed to delineate
that between the morning show um which
we do so we were doing two shows three
times a week i think yeah and uh so we
did good morning mug club and then we
found that more people were watching
both the nighttime show louder with
crowder and good morning mug club in the
morning and in doing our demo we real
analytics we realized that people
watched late night not really late at
night they watched in the morning yeah
the next morning yeah and this was a
better schedule for us we were able to
get on news more quickly and do better
because this show on like a lot of
podcasts has a lot of pre-production and
it's tough to do sometimes we'll get in
the day ahead um and then we came back
we said well the show was always louder
with crowder good morning michael it was
kind of temporary yeah and since this is
the flagship show it's just louder with
crowder so it's basically late night in
the morning i mean you know listen the
world is changing it's new media man get
with the time plus we gotta get that
intro song back yeah i love this stream
we gotta get the strange animal song
going on so there's some mud club
quarantine month was really it was it
was tough it was really valuable for us
because just doing that much content we
got to see what you all wanted most and
um yeah it really i'm grateful and how
many of you guys joined up i really do
appreciate it you guys have kept us like
we're the only people who survived the
onslaught with the vox apocalypse and
big tech and we don't have foreign
caliphate money we're not the young
turks and we don't have uh i don't know
we're target number one target number
one and i don't know what where the
money comes from from brian stelter but
i assume
it's from some black hole of
talentlessness
i will tell you this by the way last
week last thursday uh i told you this
gerald
dave wasn't here it was the third most
terrifying experience of my life
when i made myself pass out on air that
was a little scary yeah so you guys
didn't really realize it when you were
watching but what happened was um we did
the asian rosacea off and yeah token now
and was purple
and
this was round two yeah and i was like i
don't even know if i can make myself
that that red and so i did this
so he attempted so i attempted to make
myself red so you know i did that thing
and um i passed out here in the chair
you're you look like i would have to
just like hold my breath and create look
let me try and make my color the color
and then we're going to take your chat
by the way let me try to make my color
like okinawan tell me if i get close
i'm seeing some turning no you're not
getting close
no on the sides look at the sides
oh yeah yeah you can't do that oh my
gosh are you gonna see stars
i didn't i don't remember which i'm kind
of impressed you actually you started
getting a little red yeah you are i'm
gonna be of no use to you
[Laughter]
did you hurt yourself by doing that
stephen do you do you need me to
continue for you something weird just
happened oh man
do you know where you are are you like
joe biden waking up every morning
wondering i think i just might have
actually passed out i think you did i
think i could see it in your eyes i
think you passed down and so what
happened was i just remember coming to
about
uh
i don't know how long it was i have no
idea but i see this light and the andrew
breitbart sign and here's the did you
did you have recurring nightmares as a
kid that like you had a test that you
hadn't studied for right yeah did you
ever have that no okay so that was
usually you were too busy delivering
pizzas at 15. exactly for not delivering
pizzas that used to be recurring
nightmare i would have as a kid well
maybe you could relate to this thing
have you had the recurring nightmare
that like you're on stage and you've
forgotten everything yes okay so that's
a recurring nightmare that i've had
right a show or being on stage and i've
forgotten everything so here's what
happens i come to i see the andrew
breitbart sign and keep in mind when you
pass out you have no short-term memory
at all yeah so i have no idea that i
just basically
choked myself out and i look over to
gerald and i go
wait and i'm kind of floating around i
go i swear to you in my mind i go this
this isn't real this is a nightmare yeah
i'm not doing a show but you see me and
your nightmares
i'm like why did i look at you
i woke up and i'm doing a show clearly
this wouldn't happen yeah it's a
nightmare and then gerald asked me
something and it starts washing over me
yeah oh no this isn't a nightmare this
just happened and i thought
because i don't remember what just
happened yeah but i remember that i have
this you know this hard issue like did i
just have a stroke did i just have a
heart attack i thought oh my gosh i used
full spectrum cbd and it was stored in
my fat and i'm having a psychotic app
all of these things started happening
and i was freaking out
until then it came to me like oh i just
made myself pass out but i literally
told myself this isn't real this is this
is your recurring nightmare it's not i
lived my recurring nightmare and you you
overcame it i i knew like pretty quickly
i was like uh something something's
wrong and i i was like did you hurt
yourself i was trying to like see what
was going on he had that weight weird
look about you like kind of this was
like 1 45 an hour after the show well
did so did my wife watch that and you
didn't like pass out like like you
didn't close your eyes and fall back or
anything but like she said there was one
like telltale sign of what happened like
you actually had like a little shiver
like yeah really when you looked at
andrew breitbart like when you went to
look this way you kind of like your body
just uncontrollably twitched and she was
like i've seen that
before i'm not not your exactly god you
made yourself see stars for sure yeah i
usually just take the belt off my neck
oh well look whatever you do in the
private of your bedroom and consenting
adult relationships is your business
donald's
bathroom what was that we're going to
play photoshop or not and take your chat
in a second but what was that movie with
um
uh hayden christensen was it life is a
house
life as a house i think it is so there
was
a scene in that where i was watching
with my ex-girlfriend whose mom you know
i met my youtube mom was a church lady
very very nice we were watching this
film life as a house and he was
autoerotic asphyxiation yeah so in so
he's hanging himself with a belt in this
and we're watching the scene in the
movie and i swear to him sitting there
and i know what's happening and they go
it's so sad he's trying to hang himself
i said i don't think yeah i don't think
he's sad right now yep that's not what
i'm getting from this um and uh so i
just
released my gosh yeah you just can't you
can't there's no ha there's no
comfortable way to explain to someone
who doesn't know it right no actually
what he's doing let him be pure it's
okay well and you don't want to because
what if they're younger and they're like
you can what
yeah i don't give them any ideas you
don't want to tell that to a 27 year old
dave no oh no all that's required is a
belt you say is that right
all of a sudden every time you you're
going out for a walk he's like looking
at ledges and good plates like that's a
nice sturdy post what nothing no it's
gonna be a weird thing to explain at the
pearly gates if it doesn't work
so what happened uh
i fell you didn't fall you have cameras
uh let's continue oh sorry yeah yeah
that's right we got sidetracked we
digress we gotta we digress i had to
bring that up with you no no i know no
it's so disturbing to watch people is it
dunk john
i'm gonna say that photoshopped because
he would have a better makeup artist if
he had those liver spots that's
photoshopped okay as a matter of fact
i'm going to say that's photoshopped and
i think that's actually harry reid's
hands after he got beaten up by his
brother larry that might be true nice
are you ready yeah here we go
it's real
that's real what do you have an iodine
iv for well he's very old i think he's
old but he got he did something happened
to him at some point i can't remember
what it was either had surgery or a
procedure or something you know yeah
maybe he's just dead inside he's a
turtle he's become a zombie he's the
first zombie in congress he hasn't found
his new shell he looks like dana carvey
and is that going to the turtley club
yeah wow that's real all right here we
go also the funniest thing harry did you
remember when harry reid he was all
beaten up so funny and he claimed it was
from using resistance bands in his own
house
no it was a drunken bar fight with his
brother larry yes oh larry reed came in
and beat the hell out of harry reid
i'm just picturing like a cartoon
tumbleweed you know i'm rolling
and then uh then he claimed it was using
resistance bands in his shower and uh
someone who's used resistance bands even
during the corner i fell in the shower
yeah there's no way you would ever use
those resistance bands in the
shower door what are you multitasking
like
i'm bathing and working out harry and
larry reid
oh those two okay next one here we go is
it real or photoshop
oh well okay i feel like this is a trick
because i feel as though you're taking
ones that would seem real right like
that seems passable and that means it's
a photoshop because the other one seemed
photoshopped but it was real so i'm
gonna say well what do you think they're
drawing i think it's photoshop because
of the droopy left eye i think they're
trying to accentuate that well they want
to make it
want to accentuate the stroke right what
do you think there i think it is fake
yeah i think this is photoshopped too
but bring up the picture it's not
because of the droopy eye
it's because of the the lump forehead on
the right because either either um
you know one of the cardinals like gave
her a fresh one when she tried to take
communion
or
that's just disproportionate you don't
have that kind of a mouse above your eye
unless it's a hematoma so i think i like
your reasoning she just looks prettier
than usual yes
skeletor thank you for digging we all
say fake all right
it is real it is real
oh my gosh i'm o for two did you get the
first one did i i did get the first one
you got the first one did you say the
first one was real or fake i said it was
real okay so i'm oh for two you guys are
one and no no no no no one one and one
one and one i'm not good with match
i don't think that's a very basic
calculation
that i messed up it's okay why would you
pass down that zero for two all right
all
right
okay and the third one here we go third
real or photoshop real or photoshop okay
you know what i okay this is a trick it
is a trick too yes what photoshopped
those rings what do you no i shouldn't
pull that off
what do you think it's the nose rings
i've seen the picture
no he does have does he really yeah he
does have nose rings it's the beard is
not that long yeah
the beard is yeah the beard is done too
long on that one
he did have no rings but maybe it was a
stud no you got you guys already said
but the note but either way you're still
right but that is photoshopped okay all
right so i don't remember if i'm wrong
oh my gosh it's going to be embarrassing
it's photoshopped
go back to the other one real quick
and also a fuller head of hair yeah and
this is a nose ring it was complementary
you just added more decor this is like
one of those this is like one of those
exercises on the back of a children's
menu uh children's menu where it's like
a different spot the difference yeah
the beard the extra nose ring yeah the
face oh look there's a there's the
chinese communist party
we're just playing highlights and then
the map is just like you go go draw the
line through the maze from jack dorsey's
house all the way to tiananmen square
that's a straight line
oh look at that
all right here we go
is it real or photoshop
ooh i like his corn teeth
look we all get old dave who is that
perfect who is that i actually don't
know do we know did you guys that would
be prince
prince
charles
that's prince charles i'm waiting to be
king huh let me see this he looks worse
than diana now no that's camilla
all of our uk fans just tuned out
i missed it and it came back around
and i understood what are you sorry
i'm thinking uh i i i'm gonna go with
real because waiting to be king takes it
out of you
well i didn't know that was him because
now his teeth are too nice
[Laughter]
never gonna perform in the uk huh
no i love those people yeah i like john
cleese i love those goofy teeth bastards
yeah
what is centuries of inbred steven what
do you think well you didn't give me
what you
uh i i'm gonna go real on that i'm gonna
say real i'm gonna say real just because
of the genetic lineage it is it's true
it is real it is real i totally cheated
on that one too because i knew that one
i knew that was what inspired the game
oh okay yeah all right how old are you
your body just gives itself shiners like
he's just
he's just
wearing irish sunglasses
i slept on a my pillow last night
all the lumps just
i had a meeting i had a meeting with
harry and he is shirley
all right this is the final one okay oh
geez this is the show stopper here we go
real oh or photoshop
okay i think i know what you guys
what do you think there gerald he's
taking a deep look i am going with
photoshopped
oh man i want it to be fake
i don't want him to have led our country
for 10 years and then had head have he
has worse hits than she has bono and
that's terrible
they definitely have milk ducks
um i gotta go i gotta go real i'm gonna
go really real okay i'm gonna say that
this one is fake uh and just because
look bring it back up the reason i'm
gonna say fake is because of the
curvature yeah the underboob of barack
obama i agree well focused on the boob
there something else and on the wrong
boobs um
and there's something off with the
jawline of barack obama yeah
you said real you said real i say fake
all right no no no no i said fake don't
tell me okay it is
fake yeah
i am relieved wait not because of the
original this
is that's what oh you just actually made
her more feminine really he's this is
the original wait no second there's no
editing to his there's no editing
there's no editing to that man i thought
that was what was fake too
all you did was slim her down slam her
down are you no hold on a second
look hold on a second i know with your
little 23 an hour everyone who works
here that you guys think it's funny but
i'm going to be left holding the bag i'm
going to be held legally liable if
that's not the truth
that's the original photoshop that's the
original she was just slightly fatter
it's not a photoshop everything else is
the same on the back of the kids menu
that's it
[Laughter]
wow
so who won was it gerald i did i think
won all right you guys let me know if
you won there we're gonna play that
i'm like sad now
i just
i love that i just wanted i wanted his
tit to be fake and i did too no that's
all that's 100 percent obama the guy was
the leader of the free world for eight
years i didn't want to see teddy
it looks like it looks like a a
flesh-colored tube sock with a milk dud
at the end of it
it is unfortunate he really is a bad
angle
the light coming down
this way and it's like i just i didn't
think it would fall over that phone not
a bad angle it's a straight up
angle
his arms are at a bad angle oh no here's
the thing it's because of the amount of
flacidity
that even from a straight-on angle he
manages a scientific
marvel and then he presents he avails to
you under boob and sideboob at the same
time what really bothers me is that
people rated him like most beautiful man
and oh yeah beautiful man in america
yeah they're like barack obama was
really sexy he was like come on i mean
he looked yeah in joe biden's work he
was very clean and articulate yeah if i
can quote the former vice president he
spoke well but she's filthy
she's got a mouth like a sailor
[Laughter]
all right let's take chat i smelled her
once
all right joe we get it
like just smelled like plymouth gin and
used condoms
and then i realized it was my breath i
was wearing a mask
i was wearing a devil mask and i just
consumed a large amount of navy strength
plymouth gin
i put on three masks i woke up i saw
andrew breitbart i thought i was doing
the show
and i was loving my nightmare
hey look at those vin words over there
stop it joe i'm either here i'm eager to
hear
here next no no it's not sure that was
even enough it's inappropriate it wasn't
even a
nap
to their neighborhood of dc
i asked you where the restroom was and
you said buy the n-words over here whoa
joe
you can actually make a mask out of your
underwear
that's pretty bad though
[Laughter]
and the problem is that no one has shown
that when i watch it's like this can't
be real and then it is real and no one's
showing it that's just
that would have been front page
everywhere everything that donald trump
would have been impeached a third time
if you said yeah yeah for sure
absolutely yeah
talking about this it's a dog whistle
all right we're too white okay i'm
opening up my chest to do a little
laughter okay let's go to chat there
together sorry before chat we have a
breaking news update from the edit bay
wait did he actually have liquor is he
just like a narcoleptic or something
like that maybe i'm i'm coming are you
trying to make himself pass out like you
did
he was drinking sake in the men's room
that's
[Laughter]
the toilet's been you know no one's
immune from white flight
i don't know what's happening that kid
has a problem yeah that'll work he might
be narcoleptic yeah call his dad find
out yeah let him borrow him
borrow his medication yeah let me borrow
his ghb
you know that's that's the date rape
drug that you could but you can get a
prescription if you're nervous yourself
oh really yeah yeah but it was never
actually used in date rape so i knew a
guy who was a world strong one of the
world's strongest men and his big
problem was insomnia and uh he was
prescribed for a long time ghb which was
the date rape trophy but it's like super
super salty there's no way you can hide
it in anything really and you can get it
as a prescription if you're a
narcoleptic because it is guaranteed
guaranteed to give you four hours sleep
then you take a second dose and it gives
you the right it gives you the right
kind of sleep yeah it uh doesn't alter
your sleep patterns it's not habit
forming the way that like
benzodiazepines are but because you know
some people uh there was a dateline
story in the 90s you can't get it so the
ability to promise is when you wake up
your rectum hurts
there is that
just wake up and you'd wake up on the
back of a kayak yeah hell what happened
you get a good sleep but you wake up in
a frat house
all right he's asleep well listen we'll
have to check in with choi junior and
see if he has a problem i hope he's okay
that's well who what celebrity got
arrested with the date rape drug uh john
stamos was it john stamos but you know
why because it was also really popular
in the bodybuilding community yeah
arnold and those guys used to take it
because you'd get such deep sleep deep
sleep that your growth hormone would
search
so it actually is like it's actually one
of those it's very powerful but it's not
nearly as uh damaging this is what it
was explained to me actually by when i
was like i have problems sleeping yeah
we talked about it one time if people
just weren't jerks with it you know you
would be able to use it yeah yeah
for everybody so
scientists that created it wasn't like
i'm getting laid
right
yeah all right okay let's go to chat
okay
let's see so the first question comes
from hannah
as a consumer how is it possible to
protest with my dollar with every
company that i love canceling people or
doing things i can't endorse love you
guys so much and hope all of you are
doing well in texas you know you really
can't do that that's a problem you can't
do it with every company and stuff i i'm
not really the biggest fan of boycotts
just because they don't typically work
but i am a big fan of buy cots in other
words like
spend more time supporting the
businesses for example i don't even like
my pillow things like a burlap sack
stuffed with packing peanuts and i like
my pillow i know you like my pillow i
love it actually i it took me a little
time to get used to it kind of figures
pretty well that's also because probably
of what you were used to sleeping on
what did you say
i didn't like soft pillows i had a nice
white purple pillow yeah so
wait a minute i'm sorry what um huh so
it's just you know
we meet in the middle um
yeah so i think i'm a bigger i mean you
see that with chick-fil-a and then
there's the pooch yeah but you also see
it with and we've also seen it here by
the way the mug club this is a big thing
like you guys have supported us i mean
we raised we raised a ton of money for
david doran to selling through murder so
you're purchasing power unless you live
in denmark is far more significant than
simply trying to boycott like amazon and
i do think that there are some where you
make principled stands you know if
something is just so pervasive if it's a
company that is right deciding to get
involved with every single leftist cause
the nba disney is an example at this
point um i don't know the nba i've never
watched them that you're doing your job
okay there we go you're doing well
like when they only refuse to play the
national anthem of the dallas mavericks
i hate it's overused when people are
like if you don't like this country get
the hell out but if you are actually
offended by the national anthem or the
american flag
you probably should consider relocating
yeah like it's perfectly appropriate
yeah in that scenario that's your second
act your first act was supporting china
so much that you suppressed free speech
here to not offend them there right
right so yeah
okay let's go to another chat so i would
say focus on supporting businesses who
will feel it rather than boycotting
businesses who may not especially when
it's an international corporation and
you know
the american market isn't necessarily
there
necessarily even a majority of their
market but i would support the local
mom-and-pop businesses that are taking a
stand all right another chat all right
cody rs what do y'all listen to when
working out i sometimes listen to your
show but it's hard to hold a plank while
laughing well your first problem is
doing planks
planks are not bad yeah well they're not
that's right if you're playing at the
folsom street fair and that's really
more availing yourself
closest oncomer um i would say
no
i would say uh uh you know what's funny
is i don't really i often don't listen
to music yeah or i listen to like
sometimes when i when i used to work at
home like like ballads
really i didn't i don't like getting
amped and stuff because i want to focus
um sounds gay when we do brazilian jiu
jitsu i don't i always avoid anything
too heavy yeah i always want something
that kind of puts you more in a flow
state i don't know i see some people you
know they're like sitting like all right
and then they're curling in the squat
rack yeah
so um i would say here's why i don't
like planks okay go go here go with me
here you're right you know a plank is
the thing you do yeah okay um not the
meme the actual exercise okay you are
always planking when you're doing
push-ups
so why don't you just do push-ups
i mean
it's not quite the same but okay it is
the same thing it's close
it's the same thing you're always stable
you have to stabilize your core even
more with a push-up there's no added
benefit i can't do push-ups for two
minutes though maybe i could okay well
then do push-ups and then you know hold
your plank at the end of it so that your
boyfriend can you know enjoy your [ __ ]
i appreciate that enjoy your embroidered
pants
i listen to 1 25th of free bird
on double speed and then go to free
birds
i pick a song a month
[Laughter]
yeah i don't i do listen i i do listen
to news a lot though because i have to
get my work out like this morning i was
at the gym at six in the morning so
there's nothing on but i'm listening hey
look david koshner's on cnn so um
let's see this what do you think man go
whammy
um so i often listen to news i don't
really have that much time to listen to
music anymore yeah i wish i did but uh
i'm sorry that i ruined your plank but
you know what it should have been ruined
a long time ago
they're going to be doing push-ups now
like this sucks doing push-ups and
they're going to throw out an elbow from
laughing i recommend saint paul in the
broken bones
oh throw it out there i think you'll
enjoy it i don't understand the
reference and i hope it doesn't get me
in trouble no it's gonna work
phenomenal oh is it okay i'm gonna like
it if you like sam cook or marvin gaye
good music okay good good good good
listen to the boss you'll get pissed off
and you have a better workout yeah there
you go you can drink and drive in your
jeep
[Laughter]
it was right after we did the whole
segment what a piece of crap
i was like everything about this guy is
fake he's garbage and if you like his
music fine but i can't stand him and
then boom jeep's like uh he's not with
us anymore
here's my problem a shot of tequila
is what he claimed and it's like well
that's no good you should have said yeah
i had 58 beers you're supposed to be the
boss
that's weak
yeah that is just feeble i know like you
get go out on your shield man yeah you
should like you showed up that's what
happened right
i had a shot at tequila you should be
like hey screw you copper i drink when i
want
please
also try and reach for his holster
dnr dui i mean who gets that besides me
in 1990
all right final chat and then we got to
get going and then we will see you
tomorrow let's wrap this up hopefully in
a chat where someone's not doing planks
but i do appreciate you listening to the
show while you're going helpful okay
final chat is from an orlando resident
he says do you think a potential uh
presidential candidate like desantis is
better uh better off serving his state
or to make the move to president of the
united states um well you know what that
can that's a good question actually in
context way better than plank boy
which also is a horrible superhero name
oh yeah he's taking apart that building
but look at his ass
boy i can hold this for 19 minutes
i'm a child that's a terrible superpower
i like the way you said it i am
plankbook i am playing boy i am playing
boy
watch me i can ferry three to six people
across
[Laughter]
look if you ever need to walk across
burning coals he'll come in handy blank
boy
just obama
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
so i would say look right now
uh considering who is president and who
will likely be president
you know within this term um i think
he's better served running for the
presidency i agree yeah in any other
scenario if they're if they're if there
were a strong republican bench
um or if there happened to be republican
president still right now obviously
they'd be better served
uh in their state unlike that one i mean
the one year we had a million candidates
right republican candidates you don't
necessarily need that um and i do
understand the value there but right now
we're talking about not only do we need
a republican candidate but we need
someone who can appeal to both uh the
folks who weren't really big fans of
trump and the people who like that
boldness and i think desantis checks all
those boxes he's unapologetic he's bold
um he takes the fight to the left but
again he just has a little bit more
discipline and i think that he has a
little bit more appeal across all of
america so i think that he could
actually fare really well and that's
that's a pretty rare combination yeah
yeah absolutely there's a power vacuum
right now within the republican party
and somebody needs to fill it and i
think somebody like desantis feels it
really well even if he doesn't end up
ultimately getting the nomination it
allows people on the republican party
who would rather just stay home instead
of voting for trump again because they
don't want to go through the terror
whether they like trump or not they
don't want to go through what they went
through again
they'll go for somebody like desantis
and be fine you're you're holding it in
you're just thinking about playing
i was like nothing i said is funny
what
do i entertain you
just pb
i'm thankful
[Laughter]
we should
nanny can do that sketch right you can
sketch like the 50 year old basketball
player
oh he did it again listen there's no
other work that's going to get done
today because i'm incredibly immature
and i'll be thinking about plank boy
until the end of the day there you go
but uh no i agree with you everything
that you said was far more articulate
and far more mature and grown up than
anything i was gonna contribute because
i still got plank boy on the brain hey
if you like this video it's actually
clipped from the live show monday
through thursdays 10 a.m eastern that's
when you can tune in and talk with us
also you can hit the share button and
ding the bell
right that thing and that's my new catch
phrase i like it ding the bell like you
know like you're giving up on hell week
ding my bell
ding my bell
that's like that's better than roots
ah i don't like the roots yeah i mean
the movie i like the no no no the
movie's the one i like